grosse vidéo du mois de novembre quel
smartphone acheté au mois de novembre je
vais vous guider parce que vous allez
voir c'est très compliqué au mois de
novembre il y a le Black Friday c'est
les grosses promos et en plus de ça on
va enchaîner si vous regardez cette
vidéo au mois de décembre ça ira très
bien parce qu'il y a également des
offres pour Noël donc cette vidéo va
être très complète on va voir plein de
choses et une fois de plus allez chter
un coup d'œil via les liens que je vous
mets juste en bas dans la description
parce Queau moment où je tourne cette
vidéo on est début novembre il a toutes
les promos ne seront pas là et pour
autant il y aura des choses vraiment
super intéressantes donc s'il y a un
smartphone qui vous plaît foncez jetez
un coup d'œil via les liens dans la
description on va tout de suite
commencer par le smartphone le seul
smartphone que j'ai trouvé en dessous
des 200 balles parce qu'il y a des
modifications les tarifs Chang et bien
c'est le redmi note 12 4G je pense que
les redmi note 13 vont pas tarder à
arriver fin d'année année prochaine pour
l'instant on en parlera plus tard on est
à 199,90 € juste en dessous des 200
balles et là vous avez un truc qui est
très bien avec un écran amolette 120 Hz
de la recharge rapide la photo c'est pas
foufou mais globalement ça fait le taf
et ça ça le fait très bien et que vous
ayez un smartphone sur iOS ou sur
Android il faut vraiment penser à venir
le protéger c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec nor VPN qui
vous propose une solution complète pour
venir protéger votre smartphone et
regardez pourquoi la première chose
c'est que les pirates sont de plus en
plus malins et ils comptent sur votre
baisse de vigilance pour venir vous
attaquer première exemple vous êtes sur
un réseau social ça m' arrivé il y a pas
longtemps et vous recevez le message
d'un ami avec un message très inquiétant
et si ce lien apparaît là c'est que
Guillaume s'est fait avoir qu'il a
cliqué dessus et qu'il a perdu l'accès à
ses réseaux et que s'il avait eu norvpn
et bien il aurait été averti que ce lien
était malveillant et il ne serait pas
allé plus loin et il serait pas
fairenaquer deuxième exemple vous êtes
dans un restaurant un bar un café un
hôtel peu importe et vous vous voulez
vous connecter à Internet vous voyez le
wifi café gratuit vous cliquez dessus
vous connectez sauf que là il y a une
arnaque qui s'appelle man in the middle
le hotspot n'est pas celui du café dans
lequel vous vous trouvez mais quelqu'un
qui l'a créé pour récupérer toutes vos
données qui transitent par son point
d'accès autant dire que là tout votre
contenu est aspiré c'est pas ouf et si
vous aviez utilisé n VPN toutes vos
données auraient été cryptées sécurisé
et ils auraient pas pu y avoir accès et
puis allez un petit bonus en plus l VPN
va faire beaucoup plus de choses que ce
que vous pensez pour votre sécurité il
va venir scanner le Dark web et vous
informer lorsque que vous donnez auront
fuité moi ici voyez c'est mon cas il me
dit qu'il y a trois nouvelles fuites où
j'ai mon mot de passe ma ville mon pays
mon prénom mon IP et mon nom de famille
qui on fité super donc là qu'est-ce que
je vais faire maintenant que je vois ça
je vais pouvoir venir modifier mon mot
de passe modifier toutes les
informations liées à ces comptes là et
d'ailleurs ça vous intéresse obtenz 4
mois offerts sur votre abonnement de 1
an ou 2 ans à nordvpn ça jusqu'au 29
novembre et je vous mets un lien juste
en bas dans la description vous pouvez
connecter jusqu'à six appareils en
simultané et vous avez une garantie
d'être soit satisfait soit remboursé en
30 jours et merci à N VPN avoir
sponsoriser cette vidéo ensuite on
arrive au-dessus des 200 balles
légèrement au-dessus alors là on a pas
mal de choses moi ce qui m'intéresse
surtout c'est du côté de chez Samsung et
du côté de chez Xiaomi une fois de plus
ici je ne parle que de smartphone que
j'ai testé que j'ai eu entre les mains
on commence par Xiaomi on a vu le redmi
note 12 4G on va arriver maintenant sur
le redmi note 12 5G qui est quand même
très cool écran 120 Hz Snapdragon 4 gen1
bon ok ça marche correct c'est pas une
fusée non plus mais ça marchera
correctement de la recharge rapide on a
trois capteurs 48 mégapixels un ultra
grand angle de 8 et un capteur macro me
semble le ti de 2 mégapixel bon c'est
pas dingue mais ça fait le taf et à 269
€ on se dit que c'est pas mal sauf que
j'ai vu un truc de fou pour le Black
Friday on va voir chez Honor regardez le
Honor Magic 5 Lite que j'aime beaucoup
qui est un super design il est à
259,90 € normalement il était un peu
plus cher à 299 ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est qu'il y a un design incurvé un
superbe écran il est très cool il a de
bon spec également écran LED 6,67 pouces
taux de rafrachissement de 120 Hz 3
capteurs principal 64 mégapixel on a un
ultra grand tle de 5 et de la macro 12
c'est pas fou fou mais globalement ça
fait le taf et surtout il est super joli
j'aime beaucoup ce smartphone ici bref
il a tout ce qu'il faut dans les
conditions du Black Friday je vous
renverrai plus facilement vers le Honor
Magic 5 Lite que vers le redmi note 12
5G qui reste aussi quand même plutôt pas
mal chez Samsung par contre j'irais pas
regarder dans cette gamme de prix ger
sur des tarifs un peu plus élevés je
vais commencer à aller voir vers le A34
5G que là je trouve à 399 mais une fois
de plus allez jeter un coup d'œil VI le
lien juste en bas les promos vont pas
tarder à arriver il est quand même super
cool là vous avez un écran de 6,6 pouces
c'est du Super AMOLED 120 Hz les dalles
de Samsung sont toujours très bien
maîtrisé donc ici pas de mauvaise
surprise et puis bien évidemment si vous
avez un peu plus d'argent vous allez sur
le Galaxy A54 5G qui est une très grosse
référence chez Samsung 6,64 pouces pour
l'écran Super AMOLED 120 Hz un capteur
50 mgapixel principal IP67 donc
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière bon
on évite de le dans la flotte une
grosse batterie il est bien il est
efficace il marche bien la photo c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal donc bon ici
on a aussi une très très jolie
proposition si vous avez des budgets à
peu près équivalent chez Xiaomi il y a
le redmi note 12 Pro plus 5G avec un
gros capteur de 200 mégapixel de la
recharge rapide 120 W un écran AMOLED
120 Hz bref vous voyez le truc de Xiaomi
c'est que pour le même prix que les
concurrents ils aiment bien en mettre un
peu plus d'un point de vue technique
après ça reste jamais qu'une fiche
technique donc faut vraiment tout mettre
en perspective mais globalement ça
fonctionne pas mal après moi le cûp de
cœur dans cette gamme de prix c'est chez
nosing avec le phone one qui est un
smartphone de l'année dernière mais je
continue à en parler parce que c'est un
gros coup de cœur au niveau du design à
399 € vous avez la glyf interface allez
voir ma vidéo sur Youtube parce que vous
allez voir elle est quand même vachement
bien smartphone très atypique avec un os
super cool noingoos 2.0 qui est très
très chouette une proposition qui est
vraiment à part de ce qu'on trrouve
ailleurs à la concurrence et puis un
smartphone que j'ai bien aimé c'est le
Motorola c'est le hge40 Neo parce que le
H40 Neo déjà c'est un bon smartphone il
fait de bonnes photos c'est correct
c'est convenable ça va bien et surtout
alors c'est pas du tout sponsorisé avec
Motorola mais je vous le dis parce que
je vous en ai parlé il y a pas longtemps
c'està direire que jusqu'à la fin du
mois et bien il vous offre des écouteurs
de boss une fois de plus c'est pas du
tout sponsorisé mais ces écouteurs de BZ
les QC earbuds 2 ils sont vachement bien
super réduction de bruit et surtout
ilcout
294,95 € donc ça veut dire que pour un
smartphone qui coûte 399 € on vous offre
un produit à 300 balles ça veut dire
qu'en fait c'est comme si vous achetiez
vos écouteurs et vous payez votre
smartphone 100 balles donc c'est
vraiment une super propos et une super
offre une fois de plus tous les liens
sont juste en bas dans la description et
puis un smartphone qui est pas mal du
côté de chez Honor c'est le Honor 90
qu'on trouve là à
499,90 € donc juste en dessous des 500
balles alors peut-être qu'il va y avoir
des promos dessus qui vont révec le
Black Friday pour l'instant j'en ai pas
vu mais ça reste un bon smartphone super
design gros capteur 200 100 mégapixel
superbe écran bref il marche vachement
bien il y a plein de techn à l'intérieur
on aura vraiment mis le paquet au niveau
des technos donc si on veut aussi un
très joli smartphone on a aussi vraiment
quelque chose qui est super intéressant
donc c'est compliqué de venir les
départager parce qu'il y a quand même
pas mal de propositions ce que je vous
conseille c'est de cliquer sur les liens
d'aller voir les tarifs au moment où
vous regardez cette vidéo et s'il y a
pas le coup de cœur qui se fait allez
sur le moins cher que globalement ça va
venir aider votre portefeuille et ça on
aime je vous parle dans quelques
instants de gaming mais pour l'instant
on va aller sur les smartphones entre
500 à 900 balles une fois de plus c'est
une idée c'était par rapport au prix de
vente parce que les tarifs évolue
énormément notamment en parriode de
Black Friday il y a un nouveau dont je
voulais vous parler c'est celui-là c'est
le Xiaomi 13t pro que je teste avec
lequel je m'amuse et qui est quand même
vachement cool alors on est dans le haut
du panier on est quasiment à 800 balles
799,9 mais là on a les dernières techn
de Xiaomi et ce qui est intéressant
c'est un capteur qui a été conçu avec
Leica ce smartphone il est super
intéressant pour les personnes qui
aiment l'optique Leica et qui veulent un
côté photographique une fois de plus on
est quasiment à 800 € et ici y a quand
même vachement de concurrence et tous
les smartphones sont bons l'écran est
très cool avec un taux de
rafraîchissement 144 Hz ça c'est quand
même super bien alors après de vous à
moi entre 120 et 144 vous verrez pas
énormément de différence gros pros de
mdiatek le diman City 9200 plus qui fait
très très bien le taf de la recharge
rapide bref un très joli smartphone et
si vous voulez venir vous amuser ici
vous avez vraiment quelque chose qui est
super bien mais il faut vouloir mettre
800 € dans ce smartphone si vous voulez
mettre 800 € dans ce smartphone j'en a
qui aura un capteur en moins mais qui
est super bien c'est le pixel 8 et le
pixel 8 il est vachement cool pourquoi
parce qu'ici vous avez de la
photographie computationnelle ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que ce sont tous
les algorithmes de Google à base
d'intelligence artificielle qui vont
venir mouliner votre photo pour vous la
sublimer alors le seul point un peu
négatif des fois c'est que Google a
tendance à en faire un petit peu trop au
niveau du traitement mais c'est par
contre super efficace tout est optimisé
ici pour Google par Google avec beaucoup
d'usages dédié à l'univers Google donc
si vous êtes un gros amoureux de Google
et que vous voulez un smartphone qui
vous apportera de l'expérience Google
pas forcément l'expérience la plus
puissante soyons clair avec la puce
tenensor G3 3 mais vraiment tous les
usages qu'on attend un smartphone de
Google et bien vous pouvez y aller si
maintenant vous voulez maximum de
puissance c'est pas nécessairement sur
celui-là qu'il faut aller ni sur son
grand frère d'ailleurs le pixel 8 Pro
ceux pour moi sont les smartphones qui
sont très bien si on veut juste dire je
prends une photo et quoi qui se passe
queles que soient les conditions il me
sortira une superbe photo des fois c'est
un peu poussif sur des contrejours mais
ça marche toujours d'autant plus que le
pixel 8 Pro on est un peu plus de 1000
balles donc c'est la catégorie
supérieure on en parle tout à l'heure
moi ce que j'aurais tendance à
recommandé chez Google c'est le pixel 7a
parce que bien que vous ayez une puce de
l'année dernière à savoir la Google
tensor G2 et pas la G3 vous avez quand
même un super photophone tout ça à 500
balles et une fois de plus je vous le
dis en période de Black Friday peux que
vous le trouviez moins cher une fois de
plus les liens sont juste en bas dans la
description c'est un super photophone
qui vous fera tout ce qu'on attend de
l'expérience Google et ça à 500 balles
voir un petit peu moins donc si vous
voulez ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui en terme de photos à 500
balles vous pouvez aller les yeux fermés
sur le pixel 7a autre smartphone que
j'adore qui est un petit que c'est le
zenphone 10 de Asus pourquoi parce qu'il
est tout petit et qui se tient super
bien en main et qu'en plus de ça il
vient de baisser il était à 799 on le
trouve tout de suite à 699 et peut-être
encore moins cher une fois de plus je
tiens coup d'œil via les liens que vous
avez en bas vous avez un Snapdragon 8
gen 2 donc extrêmement rapide et avec un
écran de 5,9 pouces aujourd'hui c'est
super rare de trouver des smartphones
avec une petite taille déplié j'entends
avec un écran de moins de 6 pouces donc
ce qu'on retrouve ici chez Asus avec le
zenphone 10 c'est vachement bien c'est
un super smartphone très bon photophone
comp
plutôt léger très puissant et avec une
bonne autonomie c'est pour moi un super
combo si vous voulez un smartphone qui a
plus compact aujourd'hui Asus iPhone 10
les yeux fermés alors je vais passer
très rapidement sur les Xiaomi 13 qui
sont pas mal mais vu ce qu'on va
retrouver la concurrence chez Samsung j'
dirais plus facilement sur un S23 S23
plus que sur un Xiaomi 13 j'en ai déjà
parlé si vous êtes intéressé par Xiaomi
allez plutôt sur le 1t qui est la
dernière mouture que sur les Xiaomi 13
en fonction du moment où vous allez
regarder cette vidéo allez cheter un C
sur le site de Samsung parce que que les
Galaxy S23 peut être vraiment une très
très belle affaire alors là il vous le
propose au tarif le plus haut 959 €
c'est pas ce tarif là qu'il faut le
payer aujourd'hui on trouvera moins cher
j'ai jeté un coup d'œil à la FNAC voyez
j'ai des offres déjà à 849 mais je sûr
qu'on pe encore trouver moins cher pour
le Black Friday ça reste néanmoins un
bon photophone expérience logicielle qui
est très bien chez Samsung S23 S23 plus
à vous de voir mais par contre je
voudrais un tarif plus bas voyez
j'arrive à le trouver là 735 chez Amazon
je un œil sur le site de Samsung au
moment du Black Friday sinon regardez
quand même ce que vous arrivez à trouver
à droite à gauche pour toucher un tarif
beaucoup plus bas autre smartphone que
j'adore c'est le phone 2 le phone 2 de
Nothing pourquoi parce qu'on a vraiment
une expérience qui est totalement
différente c'est comme ce que je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure sur le phone one
la glyf interface derrière que je trouve
juste extraordinaire ils font un travail
de fou j'étaé les rencontré il y a
quelques jours font vraiment un boulot
extraordinaire d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est super cool le boulot que
fait noing ici PZ composer vous-même
votre musique vos sonneries enfin c'est
totalement différent noing OS 2.0 qui
marche super bien c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je vais venir totalement
recommander si vous voulez un smartphone
qui est pas fait comme les autres il
sera un un petit peu plus faiblard au
niveau de la photo mais globalement
l'expérience est tellement différente
tellement intéressante il est tellement
joli il y a un partiprix qui est
tellement fort que si vous aimez le
travail de nosing sur le phone 2 vous
pouvez y aller c'est un smartphone qui
est très performant à 729 € autre
smartphone atypique du côté de chez
crossc le stellar X5 alors je vous en ai
déjà parlé parce que crossc m'a proposé
il m'a invité à venir faire sa vidéo de
lancement et j'ai adoré le faire c'est
un smartphone que j'ai bien aimé que
j'ai un peu promené on dans les calanges
plongés on a fait plein de trucs avec on
est à quasiment 900 € c'est un
smartphone qui est pas forcément fait
pour tout le monde bien qu'il s'adresse
quand même à une population assez large
smartphone résistant pour l' out d'or
pour le bureau pour la maison pour
regarder des films des série pour tout
faire on peut l'emmener partout tout
faire prendre des photos des vidéos sous
l'eau il y a aucun problème donc si
c'est vraiment un smartphone comme ça
que vous recherchez que ce soit pour un
usage pro perso et bien vous pouvez y
aller je trouve super intéressant une
fois de plus il est très niché il sera
pas fait pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde mais si une fois de plus vous
voulez quelque chose de très résistant
qui est à la fois cool pertinent avec
une bonne expérience logiciel vraiment
plus pour l'outdoor et l'intérieur qui
mélange ces deux univers on peut aller
sur le stellar X5 à un peu moins de 900
balles et puis après il y a les iPhones
avec un iPhone se qu'on peut avoir à
partir de 529 € look très ancien pas
convaincu qu'il faille aller dessus
aujourd'hui mais si on veut un iPhone
pour pas trop cher ça peut être
intéressant ou alors voir en
reconditionner ça peut être pas mal non
plus sinon il a toujours l'iPhone 13 qui
reste un bon smartphone à partir de 749
€. en fait pour moi aujourd'hui le bon
plan si vous voulez acheter un iphone 15
c'est peut-être d'acheter un iphone 14
pro vous avez la même puce vous avez un
capteur 40 2 mégapixel et vous aurez en
plus ici un téléobjectif bien qu'il soit
pas dispo sur le site d'Apple vous avez
que le 14 vous rrouver très facilement
le 14 pro dans toutes les Bones
crémeries là je l'ai ici voyez 1100 je
trouve ça un peu cher il y a d'autres
offres un peu moins cher en
reconditionné ça peut quand même valoir
le coûpt parce que vous le trouvez quand
même moins cher et puis bien évidemment
les iPhone 15 et 15 pro dont je vous ai
déjà parlé qui sont de très très bons
smartphones après pour moi ici un des
vrais bon plan à faire c'est sur le
Honor Magic 5 Pro qui valait à la base
quasiment 1200 € et qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui a un peu moins de 900 balles
il a quand même vachement baissé et qui
est un super smartphone c'est un de mes
coups de cœur de l'année super
photophone très résistant très bel écran
j'adore réellement ce smartphone je
trouve en plus super joli très élégant
très rapide très pertinent pour la photo
la vidéo vraiment vraiment je le
recommande superbe grand écran un
milliard de couleurs très lumineux bref
si vous voulez un super photophone un
tarif extrêmement canon à un peu moins
de 900 balles et bien le Honor Magic 5
Pro franchement vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés après sur les smartphones un
peu plus de 1000 € et si je le dis je
leedis je ressigne je persiste mon gros
coup de cœur c'est celui-là c'est le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra qui est un
excellent photophone j'adore la douceur
des images je trouve très bien il est
super bien très polyvalent alors assez
gros il a un stylet avec le sen mais
pour autant il est génial il coûte quand
même 1419 € il est très cher soyons
clair donc là tout de suite je vais
mettre un peu en perspective je viens
toujours recommander ce smartphone quand
on a gros budget parce que c'est mon
gros coup de cœur mais vu aujourd'hui ce
que nous propose au nord en terme de
tarif j'aurais tendance à vous dire que
pour le mois de novembre pour Black
Friday idée et bien vous allez sur le
Honor Magic 5 Pro à moins de 900 balles
qui reste un excellent smartphone c'est
mon deuxième coup de cœur pour l'instant
de l'année en dessous du Galaxy S23
ultra sur une expérience globale dans le
très haut de gamme mais vu le tarif
franchement j'irai là-dessus à moins que
vous arriviez à trouver le Galaxy S23
ultra à un tarif à peu près équivalent à
100 ball près mais sinon globalement une
fois de plus le Honor Magic 5 Pro avant
de parler des smartphones pliants on va
acheter un coup d'œil du côté de chez
poco on va pas parler de l'expérience
gaming parce que dans tous les
smartphones que j'ai testé et bien c'est
vrai que poco s'inscrit quand même dans
une idée du gaming de par les codes
qu'on vient retrouver ici alors on voit
qu'on a des grosse promo pour Black
Friday jusqu'à 170 € on va commencer par
je veux dire plus l'entrée de gamme moi
j'ai testé les X5 et X5 pro qui sont
franchement bien ça veut dire qu'on
commence à 249,90 € avec un très bel
écran Full HD AMOLED 120 Hz un
processeur qui fait le taf c'est pas le
plus puissant soyons clair mais qui fait
globalement le taf de la recharge rapide
les photos chez poco franchement elles
sont au frais donc on y va pas pour la
photo on y va plus pour les respect et
la performance par rapport au tarif mais
ça en période de Black Friday ça peut
franchement valoir le coup après vous
avez le modèle Pro qui lui est un peu
plus cher à 299,90 € pareil écran amolet
120 Hz Full HD plus caméra principale de
108 mais une fois de plus on s'en fout
un peu la charge rapide m'intéresse le
processeur est quand même très bien la
série 7 de chez Qualcomm ça marche et
après si on peut aller un peu plus loin
on va sur les poco F5 et F5 pro à partir
de 400 balles on va monter en puissance
au niveau du processeur Snapdragon 7
plus gen 2 ça va très bien toujours un
écran AMOLED 120 Hz pour le gaming c'est
très bien et après le modèle Pro on va
sur un processeur encore plus puissant
c'estnapdragon 8 plus gen one super bien
la résolution de l'écran augmente 2K 120
Hz charge rapide 30 W bon c'est correct
529,90 € mais une fois de plus avec le
Black Friday ça peut vraiment vooir le
coût et une fois de plus tous les liens
sont juste en bas dans la description et
une fois de plus pour moi l'expérience
ultime en gaming sur smartphone c'est le
rock Phone 7 qu'on trouve en promo ça
c'est quand même vachement cool à 899 €
au lieu de de 1029 € c'est une très
jolie promo un peu moins de 900 balles
c'est un smartphone extraordinaire
puisqueune belle expérience de gaming
c'est pas uniquement d'avoir de la
performance c'est tout un ensemble tout
un expérience logicielle qu'on vient
retrouver et ici avec le rock Phone 7
c'est juste topissime vous avez les air
trigger toute l'expérience Software qui
est là il est très performant taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 165 Hz
en écran AMOLED c'est vraiment un
smartphone que je viens totalement
recommandé pour le gaming Snapdragon 8
gen 2 très performant vous avez
l'aeroactive coolleur permettra de
devenir le refroidir bref allez jeter un
coup d'œil à ma vidéo si vous l'avez pas
vu tous les liens sont juste en bas dans
la description parce que c'est vraiment
un super smartphone pour le gaming et
puis sinon smartphone pliable pour moi
celui que j'aime réellement mon gros
coup de cœur c'est le Galaxy zflip 5 qui
est juste extraordinaire alors il y a
pas mal de smartphones qui se SP j'en ai
déjà présenté beaucoup notamment du côté
de chez Motorola avec le Razer 40 le
Razer 40 ultra qui sont cool mais c'est
vrai que Samsung a un petit truc en plus
ici au niveau de son zflip 5 que je
trouve juste top le budget reste quand
même assez élevé 1199 € et il nous sorti
en plus une version rétro alors bon
c'est un peu plus cher il faut rajouter
un peu d'argent pour se rapprocher du
modèle qu'ils avaient le SGH E700 vous
voyez on est dans cet esprit là une fois
de plus je vous mets le lien juste en
bas dans la description si vous voulez
un super smartphone pliant on va sur le
Galaxy zflip 5 5G les yeux fermés alors
il existe aussi le Galaxy ZF de 5 je
vous en parle pas énormément parce que
bien que ça reste un très joli
smartphone ça reste un tarif tellement
élevé que c'est pas du tout un
smartphone fait pour tout le monde on
est à quasiment 1900 balles il a beau
être beau il a beau être bien voilà
c'est très cher une fois de plus si l'un
de ces produits vous intéressent je vous
mets juste un lien en bas dans la
description et puis je vous invite à
aller voir cette vidéo là qui vous
montre les 10 grosses nouveautés qu'on
va retrouver sur nos smartphone Android
en 2024 grâce au processeur de Qualcomm
le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 et vous allez voir
c'est extrêmement
intéressant